[Music]
if you have a Christmas tree in your
house this year it got there by a route
that would make santa claus proud
because for a few seconds at least it
probably flew on a helicopter here's the
thing for about 11 months out of the
year Christmas tree farmers in the
Pacific Northwest grow trees upwards of
8 million of them but in November they
harvest and speed is of the essence
so most of those farms rely on air
support
the dangers in flying the Christmas
trees are you're flying at a fairly high
speed and you're low to the ground if
you were to have a major problem don't
have a lot of time to react you're going
to be on the ground before you deliver
the trees often grow too close together
and on terrain to hilly and too muddy
for a truck to get to them so crews cut
the trees down but getting them from the
farm to the road requires the deft touch
of a skilled helicopter pilot
[Music]
right down here whoa right now
when the rhythms right a pilot can move
600 pounds of trees every 40 seconds
it's not easy
long lining as the pilots call it
requires special training and the
ability to control a craft whose weight
gains or losses a quarter ton in an
instant so they don't fly the helicopter
so much as fly the hook dangling about
100 feet below on a thin welding line of
Kevlar a lot of pilots that first start
out and I realize how difficult it is
until they get up there and try it for
themselves
the real hero here is momentum the pilot
decelerates the hook swings forward and
by the time it drops into the hands of
the guy screwing the trucks or the trees
the hero is already on its way back to
the other end of the course if they miss
the helo has to come around for another
pass but when it works some of these
Christmas gets married with every flight
[Music]
you